Hey there, it's Greg Nicotero, I'm here with Norman Reedus and Steven Yeun.
We have some really, really exciting news.
Walking Dead is back at Halloween Horror Nights this year.
It's gonna be at Universal Studios Hollywood and Universal Orlando Resort...
...with an all new horrifying experience.
So all that cool stuff in prison with the hordes of walkers, they're recreating that.
Last year remember, we went through?
It was so amazing, so scary.
Yeah, it was awesome.
My dad put my mom in the front as a shield.
It was so scary.
That was crazy.
My mom is so brave.
And I threw Chandler to every zombie I saw.
And it worked, right?
That's right.
All right.
Listen, you're gonna get to relive all your favorite moments...
...and it's gonna be great.
Tune in at AMC, Walking Dead returns October 13th with these guys.
Season Four.